ar is what like uh i think apple's
probably gonna make a big push to like
ar
and i think it makes sense um
for them to do that now and vr is
getting really good i just
i put an order for the valve index that
thing is [ __ ] crazy
is that a new headset yeah it's made by
a
valve so it's better than the oculus
yeah
really because it's like oriented
towards like the steam platform so it's
like written
for that and like pop that one
we tried to get the oculus but it's sold
out everywhere yeah well back order till
february well i think with the index
it doesn't cost much more to get like
full body tracking
like a weird exploration about where all
that stuff is going do you remember that
full body motion platform that
this thing came out i think six seven
years ago
for uh it's for vr and like you would
like kind of like
like you'd be tied into a ring and you'd
kind of run in place do you know what
i'm talking about
um maybe
it doesn't matter um basically that
company
they evolved the uh
the setup so now it's like a it's like
this crazy like backpack that's like on
an arm
and so you can have like full motion
with your arms like you can crouch like
i saw like some demos with like first
person shooters i was like holy
[ __ ] that's gonna be crazy and the way
they're designing it is
like it can just sit in the corner of
your room like that's your [ __ ]
playstation and it analyzes your body
yeah well that like coupled with a
headset
yeah like you can have like a full you
know but it motion tracks you you don't
have to wear
like a suit or any like yeah yeah i
think or anything
i think you have to put some things on
just so like it can try but for the most
part yeah it can
i think it tracks your feet for sure but
you can run
in place so like you could play call of
duty like with your full body
that's funny that's so sick right so
holy [ __ ] i would love to lose in real
life you know yeah
i would love to be as bad as i am dude
it just made me the controller
with my actual body the barrier to entry
on video games is going to get
so high like it's just going to become a
meme
where you have to be athletic to play
video games i'm just gonna
say that it's gonna do the full 180.
gamers are just gonna be
jacked and alpha is [ __ ] it's already
happening man
you don't think nick mercs could stand
up right now and do that
i mean exactly but you know guys like
tatman they're not going to be so lucky
but hit the hit the gym then you know
yeah you're going to have to it's going
to be a part of you
dude that's hilarious there's going to
be gamer specific
training yeah and then and then and then
nfl is going to stop being a thing and
it's only going to be
the game and fifa mm-hmm and because
you know can't do it anymore in real
life there's going to be people playing
tv and all that [ __ ] yeah exactly
well dude so wow i started out
and then and then i have to say this
here yeah a little while
dude black mirror a little while ago my
buddy was
uh showing me uh
some 3d media i think google had is
figuring this out where they've created
this
sphere with cameras and they record [ __ ]
from multiple angles and then
they can piece together 3d media
so it's like a video that plays back but
if you play it in a vr headset you can
like reach out you can like look around
the room
it's [ __ ] crazy okay and
you know the quality is pretty good so
just made me think that
i think in very quickly i think movies
are not going to be
2d anymore like yeah they've tried to do
that though
but i think it was too early yeah when
you have an iphone 14
and it comes with a set of goggles and
people are like oh my god have you seen
the new black mirror season you're like
no it isn't you just put on your [ __ ]
your ar goggles and you go to your
netflix app
yeah and the movie just [ __ ] around
the room
get out of here i know i know you're
probably right
and i know i'm just gonna say it's gonna
take a lot a lot of time to get used to
like looking around in a movie
like you have to watch a movie like five
times
i mean yeah i think i think you know it
will take a while to figure out what
works
but i just think the the start of the
switch is going to happen pretty soon
yeah i think 2d media is going to go out
yeah i mean i it's funny that you
brought this up because
after using that headset for a little
while and playing like beat saber and
all that [ __ ] i know i'm like pretty far
behind on that but
it's mind-blowing and every single
person you put it on who's using it for
the first time is like
holy [ __ ] i'm obsessed with this yeah
right away
did you play that boxing game no i
didn't whoa
amazing what is it uh oh it's just like
um there's the there's two but the one i
have is
the creed boxing games like based on the
movie creed
um the actual like punching isn't super
accurate or true to life but
the the vibe of like standing in front
of something and like
moving and all that is is wild um
i'm gonna get that vive one yeah i'm
well i'm hyped for the index because uh
but the it's just it's just so much
better of a headset and there's so much
[ __ ] you can do
and i was looking at a crazy battle
royale where
you can um it's like it's like any other
battle royale but you can
uh when you parachute like the mechanism
to do that like you can climb up a
building
and then push off and then spread your
arms and like you'll it's like a
squirrel suit you'll like fly
to another location oh my god yeah
yeah yep i get that man yeah kelsey's
obsessed with it too
she's like playing beat sabers like we
have to get one of these
oh yeah it's so much fun the ladies love
beat saber
[Laughter]
they just love beat saber homie
[Music]
she probably just wants it for vr porn
too
wow there's a guy with a normal sized
dick
um can i tell you what we did i just
back on the justin bieber thing
so we
i had one more thing no it was unrelated
to vr i decided one more thing that i
forgot to tell you so
we're sitting there we can't buy it
because whatever website they use to do
the
ticketed live stream [ __ ] up of course
they used some stupid startup in it
and it [ __ ] up and so uh we were like
looking for it everywhere and every
stream was getting shut down we finally
found it on twitch this person was
twitch streaming it
right and so we're like dope and um
we're watching it and then we realized
somebody subscribed randomly and so
we realized the sub alert was like super
loud and it was turned down for what
oh nice like turn down for me
and so i i gifted 50 subs
each one on the crescendo of the song
so it was like he was playing uh
you know sorry yeah and it was like
right as the course is about to hit turn
down for what would
turn on so [ __ ] loud great job
half the chat was like oh my god stop
doing this and half the chat was like i
gotta sub i'm so stoked
the hardest i've laughed in a long long
time terrorizing
this dream man you're trolling at its
finest dude
and paying to troll too that's another
that's a whole new level yeah a whole
new world man
i love it you feel like you deserve it
yeah you you deserve the right to trust
exactly i just felt like a 14 year old
kid you know just
yeah bro ar vr
we're going to be um i mean i tweeted
this by standbys we're going to be
[ __ ] brain dead in five years we're
not going to drive for ourselves
we're just going to sit and eat amazon
mush like there's gonna be like an
amazon camel pack that has like burgers
and
fries and okay just like [ __ ] tasty
sludge
yeah you're gonna load it into a camel
pack you're gonna put that in your mouth
you know put on your ar
and the self-driving car takes you
wherever you need to go and just [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah you order on a little you
order on a little like menu
on the seat in your auto driving car
and you say oh i like the shake shack
the shake shack new korean fried chicken
sandwich that looks good korean little
chicken
ice cream sandwich ice cream sandwich
yum yummy with sprinkles on it yes
please add sprinkles add whipped cream
add avocado add avocado and then this
thing
comes up for the from uh what kind of
bun brioche i'll do a nice brioche bun
and then slide though with uh with
[Laughter]
onion rings coleslaw and um
and um and birdie bot's every flavored
beans yeah
all three yummy all three love it
and so then this hose comes out of the
floor
it's uber it's still uber right you're
still taking an uber this is auto
driving uber and now ubereats is built
into the car
and so this little hose comes out of the
ground
and it just right in your mouth and then
it just hoses the liquid food and you're
sitting there in your vr headset
yeah watching porn watching porn with
your mouth just like
and there's a catheter and there's no
catheter
the seat just has like a hole in it oh
okay yeah and we wear like that we wear
like these new era like
yeezy pants where they're like tear away
on the ass yeah
but like not all the way like you just
pull the cheeks and they go
and it just reveals your crack and you
just line it in
yeah and then you and i
was coming out the other side and you're
watching james charles makeup tutorials
cycling in the car and then you know and
i know you guys are wondering well what
happens if
it runs out of ubereats how will i order
or what if there's too much [ __ ] in the
car it's fine the amazon drone
flies to the car and it you know you
know how like airplanes refuel in the
sky
it's going to be like that a drone's
going to meet you on the road and will
either empty out all the
[ __ ] or refill the uber eats in the
auto driving uber yeah
and here's the best part now that all
jobs are remote you don't have to go
anywhere
yeah you just drive around maybe you
live in the uber car
yeah it's just perpetually
it's going and going and going
it's gonna be [ __ ] up man
i'm looking forward to it personally
everyone everyone's going to be like
that's why the robots are going to kill
us because we don't do
we won't do anything at that point like
we'll be a distant
image of what humans used to be robots
will look at us and be like
they used to play football and
basketball and tell jokes and have
culture and art
now they just eat [ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ]
24 7.